and it's all improv does it be magic to
us to like we don't practice anything we
get on stage and we go
you know I mean we got my man Craig
right here I'm gonna attest to that we
never sit around and have no meetings
about I Pro we in this city so this what
we go none of that because it's so
genuine and like I said that energy that
I was talking about it's so strong and
it's so genuine that when we get on
stage it's literally magic
[Music]
[Music]
so let me just I'll just welcome you to
the show and then we'll kick it off all
right no you're good and that's for you
as well that's hot breath water
exclusive breath breath water yeah it's
got the he's got the logo on there for
you it's all for you man so here we go
hop read the verse welcome back to
another hopper episode I'm your host
comedian Joel Byers
this is hot breath your weekly guide to
comedy mastery and today's guest hot
brethren and sistren not only a master
of improv not only a master of stand-up
comedy but also a master of mindset this
is a cat lost his dad at two years old
grew up in DC and what they called the
shadows of the US Capitol since been
able to create his own success through a
solid foundation with family but also
through a solid foundation of mindset
went to college graduated jumped right
into comedy and now we see him as a
comedy superstar but he didn't just roll
over one day and become that this cat
actually lost his job then the next week
actually books wild and out but not
after having to fly to a wild down
audition after selling his clothes at
Plato's Closet to be able to buy the
flight to get there so this is going to
be an example of if you put your mind to
it you can achieve it but it's also
putting in the work so he has since
Wilding out of course since 85 south
show and now hot breath podcast listen
man let me just say whoever your
research person is is amazing
all right that's how you end up give me
all water yeah yeah yeah good research
people coming I need to get more white
people working right now exactly your
white person so that's what I'm saying
giving you your props push it my
pre-show I like what you're doing yeah
yeah we've had we've had Carlos Miller
on here a couple times have clayton
english on here we've had chad we've had
85 squad out here that's what it is now
we got you got me that's what it is man
I'm happy to be here with you so I would
really like to dive into your your
mentality behind what you do because in
researching you you are one of the
funniest people
alive but then when you hear you in
interviews you're always spitting wisdom
you're all you have you know brother
knowledge if you were yes that's just
that you know oh everything that I do is
kind of not even kind of is a reflection
of who I am as a person how I grew up
like you have a lot of people who you
know take negative experiences and they
let it affect them you know and
detrimental II like not choose not to
everything that I've been through is you
know just a reflection of who I am and
what makes me unique as a person so you
know like brother knowledge is just
something that came from my head you
know I grew up around my uncles so I had
two uncles that were actually in the
Nation of Islam so just that influence
and seeing those guys as a young man and
how serious they were about the things
that they say and it's funny as the
videos are it's always a real message
within them and um you know most of the
knowledge that I received from them
always came that way because me being a
young man they knew they couldn't give
it to me in a manner in which I wouldn't
be able to comprehend it so they were
able to give me you know understanding
through a level of me being able to
comprehend the message that they had so
you know it's just me kind of paying
homage to one of those things that you
know helped make me the person that I am
when it comes to me being me you know me
and people are striving and me
personally as well you know I'm not
aiming for the middle when my stand-up
or this podcast or anything so someone
and you're by no means at like the peak
at all and we know that was just getting
started
and that's what's amazing is you haven't
even really been in the game that long
and in terms of this being a lifelong
journey right so what do you attribute
to like such a quick rise like is it the
mindset is that the secret sauce and I
don't even really think it was a quick
rise to be honest with you because in
this game a lot of people believe that
your journey starts when they start
caring about it and that it really
doesn't work like that your journey
starts when it starts once people start
to pay attention to it then that's when
they kind of give you the credit for
kind of starting the race and that's
respectable because that's the way
things go but for me my journey started
when I got on stage for the first time
at the open mic night in Greensboro
North Carolina at the comedy zone so
from that point until me sitting here
with you right now is all a reflection
of the journey that I've been
and continue to walk so you know I did
my first four minutes in 2008 so I've
been going ever since 2008 I just put a
post up yesterday that uh you know said
that you're just talking about my car
used to break down I had a Saturn V
there at 332 thousand miles on it
I took it to trade it in and the guy
from the dealership came out and was
like look man you ain't got nobody you
can bless with this man we're gonna baby
get you nothing for so so those are the
things that people don't see you know me
having to walk home from the repair shop
two miles cuz my car broke down and the
pair of hard bottoms cuz I was leaving
my line brothers win and it made me have
a different respect for Martin Luther
King and him I'm like if they did this
daily I respect them from being able to
walk and rest shoes like this is not the
test that I would want to take on every
day for freedom so those little things
that you learn over time you know the
things that make you appreciate the
journey that you own because for me I
realize now that the point that I'm at
now in my walk what keeps me humble and
understanding that the work that I do is
that all the things that would be
considered to be nuisances or problems
in my life now six seven years ago would
have fixed everything that I had going
on they would have been the solution so
I got a I had to pay $3,000 in flights
for the next month seven years ago
$3,000 would have changed my whole
situation right you know so it keeps me
understanding that importance of being
able to recognize you know you have an
obligation to yourself first and
foremost to make sure that you have
peace of mind and then you also have an
obligation to your craft to make sure
that you never take anything for granted
because you know I respect people's
journey who go up the elevator I mean
it's cool you know I mean I however you
get there I'm not concerned with anybody
else's journey but my own but I respect
the fact that I walk up the steps and
I'm continuing to walk up the steps
because and I would you know I much
rather not saying there's anything wrong
whatever works for you is for you but I
must rather go up the steps then go up
the elevator I have to walk down the
steps because when you got to walk down
the steps then it's a whole side and
process of this game that you don't know
about but when you
you meet all the people on the steps and
you learn how to navigate your way
through you know the trips and Falls and
you know you see all of those different
things on your way up you know in the
hands that you shake on the way up these
are people who take the same journey as
you take so you build relationships with
people that always be able to utilize
what you do and vice versa so you know
it's just the way it works all right you
know I haven't been in the game for a
long time in comparison to what they say
it takes to really become a superstar we
a baby in the game yeah as far as my
journey I really started walking up the
steps the whole way so you know where I
am on the steps might not be what
somebody may believe I should be your
somebody might not think that is you
know you as successful as you could be
but luckily for me I don't base with
anybody else thinks on what it is that I
do and that's what I admire about your
your approach to it as well as cuz I say
it was quick because I've been in the
game nine years alright so I start 2010
so it's like thinking well in nine years
it's like oh someone like Chico was
already like here even it's it's it's
easy in this game to start comparing
yourself to other yeah you shouldn't you
shouldn't compare yourself to anyone
else because nobody journey is yours but
yours and it can become difficult not to
because you know you you're basing your
success off of what you believe success
to be in the industry that you're in and
um you know I I can respect people who
don't know how to navigate out of that
but for me and like I said my background
is really really different I've never
been the same as anybody else you know
so I've always had to learn how to
operate within the space that was unique
I said my father was killed when I was
two most of the males in my family were
involved in some type of illegal illicit
activity you know my mother didn't
graduate from high school you know I
mean like all of these things made me a
unique person and I always had to
embrace the fact that I was unique like
when sometimes my friends would be
outside playing football and basketball
in the street I would have to walk to
the Safeway the grocery store with a
cart and get all the groceries for the
house and walk past all my friends
playing outside which I had to learn how
to embrace because I didn't have a
choice
so you have a choice in life when you
have to do things that you can't control
like we all have
responsibilities that you don't have any
option as to whether or not you have to
complete got to pay your bills you got
to drink water you got a bus nuts [ __ ]
like that you know I mean so it's like
those are the things that you have no
control over anything that you have no
control over them in my opinion the best
way that you can embrace those things is
to take the things that you do have
control over and make them and cater
them to you in the best way possible so
you don't have to worry about the stress
of those things causing you to be
negligent in the things that you can't
control
soon that was something that I was able
to do and had to figure out very early
in my life like it wasn't something that
I had a choice in so me having to figure
those things out young kind of prepared
me for what it is that I'm doing now you
know we live in a time where you can
give your pump opinion publicly and
privately at the same time you can tell
me how unfunny and ain't [ __ ] I am
without me even knowing what your face
looks like so me having to go through
life and learn the things that I learned
as a young man prepared me for the
industry that I'm in now because I'm not
affected the same way that other people
are affected by those things because
I've had to do it when nobody knew me
but the people who knew me and I still
had to engage and you know life amongst
those people and still be cool with
having a you know complete tasks that
were given to me by somebody who I
didn't have a choice as to whether or
not I was gonna do it or not so that's
where the mature mindset yeah yeah
definitely definitely definitely because
you know I I see people all the time who
you know allow things that happen to
them to be used as an excuse to not you
know do whatever it is that they're -
yeah oh man this happened to me and I'm
from this place and I did none of that
matters you know I mean and that's just
my personal opinion but don't none of
that matter cares about your plight only
you care about your plight and only you
I ever be able to care about it in the
capacity that you you know ever gonna be
able to make any real change about it so
for me I understand that there's no way
for me to be able to be successful if
I'm not basing the success off of what
success is not what the society believes
success is or what the person next to me
believed success is I have to establish
my own success so therefore I can relish
in the things that mean something to me
and that'll carry you throughout the
cloud of you know comparing yourself to
people or not getting that opportunity
or getting told no and all of that all
of that or you know it doesn't matter
because once you establish your
successes it doesn't matter if anybody
else looks at your success and says it's
not we're supposed to be so that's
something you would recommend comics do
starting out is establish what successes
yes yes definitely establish what you
want and don't make it vague all I want
to be the next Kevin Hart I want to be
the next bill burr I want to be tan
there's already a Kevin Hart and Bill
burr so how are you going to do what you
need to do to become the first you you
know I mean and it doesn't have to look
the way that people say it looks you
know I live in North Carolina to this
day I went to college in winston-salem
North Carolina and I still lived it when
I graduated college I didn't want to go
back to DC because I knew once I
established that I was going to do this
for a living once you start to hit those
pitfalls it's a little different when
people that know you are inquiring about
you
you know well-being you know if a
stranger says all you ain't [ __ ] you
shouldn't be doing this okay but when
your mom is like baby what's going on
you know it's not coming from a place of
malice she's really concerned about your
well-being so therefore you have to make
sure that well at least I had to make
sure that I didn't allow that to affect
me because I didn't know how it would
because I never dealt with that before
but I have dealt with you know my mom
influence on me and I know they're not
just using her as an example just
because that's probably the biggest
opinion that I accept in my life as far
as somebody who knows me I've never felt
or experienced what it felt like to have
her see me fail in a manner where there
was nothing to fall back on but my own
merit if I failed at school it was you
know a curriculum that wasn't being
followed if I failed at sports it was a
curriculum there wasn't being followed
when it comes to making your dreams come
true there
no curriculum you know I mean there's no
blueprint so you have to create it I'm
creating a blueprint for me and my
family name you know so I I didn't know
how I would deal with my mom seeing me
you know catch them ales that you catch
doing this as a you know career and
looking and like you know baby you don't
have to go through this you good enough
to do anything do something else so I
stayed why I didn't know anybody I had
to make it work and it's you know North
Carolina's not a hotbed of talent
nobody's really coming there to look for
talent it's plenty of talent they're
just like it's plenty of talent
everywhere but it doesn't have the name
of a New York or LA Atlanta so if you
can make a name for yourself in that
space then you're doing something so
that's the way I challenge myself and I
still live there now because it provides
a level of peace of mind to me that I
can't find anywhere else and I'm totally
fine with that being the case when you
establish your success do you like do
you have it written down somewhere or
here is the vision I mean I started out
writing five point plans for myself this
is just something I learned from just
coming from the community that I came
from an it guys they influenced me
growing up I would five years five
points and I can't move from one or two
until I complete one you know I mean so
I started in oh wait and supposing I get
myself five years to complete these
things and now I'm on what you know I've
been doing this coming up on eleven
years in August and I morning what my
fourth 5-year plan because I've
accomplished the things that I wanted to
accomplish whoa that many times already
so it's like I challenge myself every
day you know every single day that I
wake up I challenge myself to become a
better version of me I want to be the
best version of Chico being that I can
be on a day-to-day basis and the way
that I do that is by developing a
program that's based on Who I am
first figuring out what that means
figure out who you are as a person
embrace it whatever it may be you might
get scrutinized or criticized but as
long as you're not hurting yourself or
hurting anyone whatever it is you do is
cool so once you figure out what those
things are and
verse that then it becomes easier for
you to find the level of success for you
because you're basing it off of you and
you took that journey of figuring out
who you are as a person I think a lot of
the reason why comedians get lost in the
sauce when they come to this game is
because they're basing their self-worth
off what they believe other people based
self-worth off but it shouldn't work
like that if it's if something's not for
you is not for you but if you're chasing
it even if you accomplish what it is
you're chasing once you accomplish it
it's gonna really [ __ ] you up because
when you get there you're gonna realize
I did all this work for some [ __ ] that
doesn't even satisfy me in any capacity
so now you you know lost because you
feel like I've gotten there I'm
successful now cuz I got you know show
or whatever I'm doing in some headline
and I'm making money but you don't have
any inner peace you don't have any type
of knowledge of who you are so now that
you've accomplished this goal whatever
your goals may be if you're not basing
it off who you are when you get to that
point you won't realize I don't waste it
however many years of my life chasing a
goal that wasn't even my goal to
accomplish you know I mean it seems
environment is very important and
surrounding yourself with people yeah
I've done over a hundred and seventy of
these episodes and it seems a common
theme with successful people is they
surround themselves with like people in
that higher-self mindset yeah but that
I've been blessed in regard to that as
well because when I came in the game as
far as when people start caring and I'll
say that's when we got on wild and out
okay and lows came in at the same time
and you know loss is old I've been in
the game longer and has been a mentor in
a lot of ways but we mentor each other
in a lot of ways just in life but to
come from nothing with a person I'm
talking about walking up and down the
street going the Western Union to send
fifty dollars home and washing your
clothes in the basement of the hotel to
being able to do what we're able to do
now at this point it's just a reflection
of it doesn't matter what points you're
at in regards to the people you surround
yourself with answer your question as
long as you surround yourself with
somebody else who has the same mentality
in regards to who they are
hmmm I love Who I am those are the
people I want to be around I don't care
what you do but if you you and you
embrace who you truly are and you stand
on it like hey that's what I like this
what I don't like take it or leave it
those are the people that I want to be
around because I can learn something
about life that I can't learn living my
own cuz I'm living mine the same way you
are so when we come together we're
teaching each other about the world
based on reality and that's how you
build that energy that ends up
attracting the type of success that you
want in your life and to finding
yourself sounds it man it sounds like oh
I just find myself you know like right
down is a journey like where I came from
yeah it's a journey it's a journey like
I've been through a lot of things in my
life you know a whole lot of things that
most people wouldn't be able to handle
you know I've seen those things that you
see in movies and stories I've really
witnessed and lived through those type
of things so life is different for me
one of the first things I had to learn
how to deal with in life is death
because my father got kid when I was 2
years old so once I came in the
understanding of who I was that's the
first thing that I had to recognize and
acknowledge that the person that is
supposed to be here is not here and
never will be
so learning to accept that alone makes
you find something within yourself
that's different but throughout life
I've dealt with that many many times
over you know my uncle Reggie was killed
in OH - cousin Dirk I can you know only
want to get into the long list of names
and situations but all of those things
have made me look at life differently
than most people look at life I don't
view life the same way as everybody else
I understand how it works from a
different perspective I know what it
feels like to have somebody say I'm
gonna see you later and you never see
him again you know I mean so I'm always
looking to figure out who and what I am
on a day to day basis because I went to
my father's grave site for the first
time when I was 21 years old he was
buried in the older part of the
graveyard lady took me back over to
where he was buried at and pointed at
the grass and said he in this area
somewhere
I'm like damn I don't even know if I'm
gonna be talking to the right
[ __ ] and I mean like and that
was just the natural thought of what I
had most people would have been
devastated but me going through life
having to figure that out so early it
was something that I accepted and had to
figure out at that moment of how I was
going to embrace this being a reality
going forward and the reality is
whatever this man had done in his life
up into that point when someone took it
hadn't been enough to gone to himself a
marker to let the world know that he was
here so my job in this being my reality
is to do my best to not have this be my
reality going forward you know and those
things made me have to find out who I
was a little bit differently than
everybody well a lot of people are gonna
say everybody cuz I'm sure a lot of
people have journeys that are just as
unique but that was one of the things
that made me have to figure out who I
was truly because that's my reality I've
never had a basketball game or a fight
or a show or nothing that this person
was present for and when I went to go be
present to where the remains that he
left him were there was no way of me
even finding out where that was so at
that point you have a choice you can
either sulk and feel sorry for yourself
and like woe is me or you could say well
I I have a responsibility to make sure
that whatever I do here is going to not
only just leave a marker but leave a
marker that lasts way longer than once I
they put me in the grass or whatever
they put me at yeah and I have found
that long-term perspective of okay what
will this look like in five years or ten
years and that self-awareness that I'm
I'm being more mindful of trying to hone
in on self-awareness and conduct my
decisions based around who I am and
where I want to be so like personal
example for me and you may have one it's
like I got offered like a TV show where
I was paying us I was playing a slave
master and I was like yo in like five
years
I'm not gonna want to be like this was
my debut that I played like a slave
master you know so it's like having that
self-awareness and that long-term view
of like okay this may be a
bump now but it may be like a pothole
later like always having that long-term
view seems to be helpful well I think
it's our perspective and I really
believe that I believe the world is
based everything is based on perspective
because it's always another way of
looking at whatever it is that you got
going on cuz the energy that you put out
is what you're gonna receive let's say
you did play a slave master look at the
reality of it you would have probably
been a slave you wouldn't been a slave
you know I mean yeah so it's like the to
be able to explain that to people if you
ever need it to what you don't cause you
don't have to explain yourself to
anybody but the people who you allow to
have influence in your life so you have
to that's another thing you have to be
very selective and strategic on picking
those people whose opinions you allow to
affect your actions but once you get
that established then you know that's
the opportunity that you if you did take
it like hey this is the reality of what
the history is and I was given this
opportunity but there aren't slaves
anymore not a slave master I could never
be a slave master but I can play one on
TV you know I mean so it's all about the
way that you look and I said it the way
that you did it was wrong because if
that's the way you were supposed to do
it then you did what was right for you
but it's all perspective because the
same way that you didn't take that role
whoever took it had the perspective of
you know what else I need this right I
mean and some people might have just
needed it for the money or some people
might have needed it for the opportunity
some people just like I'm a challenge
myself I'm so against that to be able to
put myself in the position of being
something that I would never agree with
is you know a challenge for people who
entertain so I can understand all
perspectives but for me I just really
think that you know the energy that you
put out into the world is going to draw
back the results that you you know want
to see or don't want to see so as long
as your energy is right then you gonna
be able to accomplish whatever it is you
set out to accomplish you know I mean
that's why I appreciate about your game
is you understand the art of the
independent hustle and creating your own
success and now with the internet and
everything comedians can do that more
than ever right it's like what are some
ways or tips you have for comics who
should or who
just build their own foundation well
it's easier now than it's ever been
because you know 20 years ago if this
was you know my reality I would be all
of us really especially the people on
Wilin out just to use that as an example
would be a whole lot more famous if the
internet didn't exist hmm because if the
internet didn't exist the access to us
would be a whole lot less you know than
it is now so you think when in living
color was on but they were superstars
because the odds of you being able to
have contact or interact with them or
let them know how you feel about him
whether it be negative or positive it
was very difficult you had to write a
letter and then get a letter back and
then write another letter and then you
know I mean like it's different now now
you have direct access to anybody
Beyonce is the biggest star in the world
but you can go on her Instagram page and
type of comment in her comments and the
odds of her seeing that are a whole lot
more than the odds of her seeing the
letter 20 years ago in a 15,000 letters
a day so just utilize that aspect and
whatever it is you want to do I don't
care what it is if you want to be a
comedian if you just want to be an
Instagram entertainer start that's the
biggest thing most people just sit
around and don't start you can talk a
hole in your head but until you stop
putting forth the effort the university
they gonna give you nothing back because
you haven't given anything to work off
so you got to put forth some type of
effort just I tell people that all the
time people come up and be like I want
to be a comic well have you done any
standup
I don't care what you do especially
college students we do a lot of colleges
and they'd be like man I want to be a
comedian I'm like man you're in college
they have to utilize funds to let you do
what you want to do do it while it's
free cuz once you leave here
nothing's free anymore everything costs
money so the best thing you can do why
you here is utilize this place who is
put here to help advance you as a human
being and do it for nothing but it
doesn't cost you anything and you learn
the game so when you get out here and
have to use your money you
we built some type of foundation if you
have a skill set at it that's gonna
follow you and it makes it a little bit
easier for you to get out here and start
the press and push your envelope because
you've already started in the place
where it didn't cost you anything and
that pressure financial stability wasn't
on you you don't have that when you're a
college student and for those people who
aren't and just trying to do it on their
own you can go to Rite Aid and buy a
cell phone you know I mean and you can
go to Starbucks and get Wi-Fi so it's
really no excuse now for you not to be
able to put for some type of effort you
you can't cheat the game you have to put
in the work you have to get out here and
put your feet on the pavement and do
something and once you start doing
something then you'll start to see the
results of you doing something and you
got to be able to recognize what success
is because even if you you know go from
I remember the first Instagram posts I
put up got 12 likes I mean and I was
excited about the fact that I got 12
didn't show the names and the number you
know I mean but that's the difference
that was the first 12 and I was excited
about that first 12 and I embraced that
first 12 to get to the next which was 24
and then you know 36 and then on and on
and on but the only way that happened is
putting the effort forth and embracing
the moment that you are in like the walk
is the walk you got to embrace the ugly
Carlos me and Carlos say that all the
time you got to embrace the ugly like
rest in peace and nipsey hussle he had a
quote a say sometimes you just got to
cut out all the fun cut out all the
[ __ ] get ugly and grind mm-hmm
you know I mean that's the reality of
what you have to do those days when I
was how I got 300 32,000 miles on the
saturn vue is because i was out here in
it moving around every day doing
something working a regular job and
doing this for no money just to get
myself in a situation where my energy is
starting to match what i need to come
back to me
because I'm putting forth the type of
effort that people are gonna see even if
you don't like what I do if you're
watching I'm gathering all of that and
it's helping propel me to the next step
and the only thing that getting to the
next level and anything that you do it
just gives you a better view of what you
can't get to you know I mean it's like
if you can't see over the edge when you
finally get up over the edge then you
see everything that's over the edge so
the more you climb and grow
it never stops you know I mean in the
things that you chase never stop jay-z
just became a billionaire but he's still
working Bill Gates and all these
different people and you know I don't
even everybody
that's successful they still work
because it's not about the money it's
about the view it's about what you get
to see because the money is just all
money to me in my opinion and I say this
all the time I hope everybody gets the
money so you can see that it doesn't do
anything but just makes the things that
you can't control easier to deal with
money is like like a moon bounce kind of
you know I mean like in life we fall
down and we ain't got no money when you
fall down you hitting a concrete
straight concrete scraping your knees
bust your head open you know I mean
bleeding gotta lick your wounds and get
up and you're limping to the next thing
but the more money you get now your moon
bounce starts to blow up so when you
fall now you don't hit the concrete you
just bounce back up mm-hmm
so that's all it does it just allows you
to be able to buy some [ __ ] that you
want and not have the things that you
can't control that life is gonna give
you cause you to just break down you
know I mean I remember when my car used
to break down that [ __ ] used to stress
me out because it's like damn now I got
to come up with $900 to get some ball
bearings when my rent is due like what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do
that's what money does de-stress it
eliminates that aspect but the more you
get then you just go into a different
bracket of stress so all you're doing is
just blowing up your mattress and
blowing up your moonbounce rather so
when you know you
you fall down at you bump your head if
somebody comes it's just a cushion but
the real success comes from the view it
comes from what you get to see from your
work like I didn't know that this part
of the world existed before I got to
this point and money can't buy you that
like money can't buy you the experiences
that you have when you really work
towards your goal like I've had people
who I grew up just idolizing walk up and
say my name to me before I can even open
my mouth
Chico what's up with you man it's no
amount of money they can buy that that
view is what it's about so it's like
once you figure those things out and
once you start to put forth for effort
then that's what the universe that give
you if you really genuine and like I
said in my opinion I really believe if
you're not hurting yourself knowingly or
hurting anybody else normally everything
that you do is going on at you some type
of result yeah I'm at a point now my
career where it's the money is becoming
a little bit more of like a factor and
maybe a motivator just for the sheer
fact of just wanting to start
reinvesting it into everything I'm doing
start doing what I'm doing but just at a
higher let me ask you this question do
you come from money no no no no podunk
like I look purebred but I'm inbred okay
yeah yeah oh really so yeah are you from
originally Summerville Georgia some of
your George example some villainville
some VMV Oh somewhere yeah some Vila
Georgia parents educators like I come
from like a like a connected and strong
background in terms of a service
background you know but yeah I don't
come from money or anything like that
but see even that like one thing about
financial status is that you know most
of us and then when I say yes I mean
black people have never had anything
mm-hmm
so it's one thing to get some money but
what you're gonna do with it
when you get it cuz getting it is a
whole lot easier than keeping it hmm
yeah I mean to get it you can get some
money about how you gonna keep it and
that's a whole nother journey that you
have to take to learn something that
you've never had before it's like if
I you know if you look at it like this
and for some reason people don't equate
it and their minds like this but I do
but if I walk into a judo class today
I'm gonna get the [ __ ] beat out of me
I'm gonna get tossed around and beat up
because I don't know what to do
I have to learn what to do money is the
same way if you walk into some money
today you're probably gonna get tossed
around and get [ __ ] beat out you because
everything that you think works you have
no idea you just assuming that it works
because you never had nothing and you
feel like all I needed some money and
that's gonna fix everything that's going
on with me and it'll fix a lot until you
realize that what you need to be fixed
can't be paid for you know I mean so
it's like I'm for financial stability
just because I like to have the moon
bounce I like to have that ability to be
able to eliminate stress for my loved
ones and I have the problem of worrying
about man this happened or this happened
that's the beauty of financial stability
to me the beauty of having some money is
being able to you know something happens
and you know like [ __ ] toilet breaks
or your sink breaks down oh it's gonna
be a thousand dollars cool that just
that right exactly that's the beauty of
having money to me other than that
everything else is something that's way
bigger than any dollar amount can ever
give you that's what a real word comes
in to get those things to be in a place
where you could be on a bus in Australia
like I was I had people walk up to you
and I'm on a metro bus in Australia
which I probably had no [ __ ] benna's
being on anyway but I'm just goofy like
that walk up and show you a video and
they phone at him watching you do the
work that you do and I'm in Australia
being paid to be there to shoot a pilot
for a show that never came out
mmm so does that mean that I'm not
successful because it never came out or
am i successful because I got the
opportunity to go to the other side of
the world and work and get paid for it
it's all perspective it's all how you
look at it when you're scrapping again
how important is saving verse
reinvesting and like what you're doing
you got to invest in yourself you got to
spend money on you know whatever it is
you do but it's levels to that it's
different elements to that like I have
been a person who has been in the
fashion my whole life just because I
grew up in the house with a lot of
people who will fly and that's just
something that that I picked up on and
that's an investment and to me because
I'm a performer clean and neat
that's my auntie used to tell me you
can't accomplish anything in this world
along as long as you clean and neat as
long as when somebody sees you they look
like you you can start a conversation
with anyone and if what you have won and
what you look like is natural for you
like I just got on a you know black
sweat top and some black shorts but it's
genuine I'm comfortable so when I walk
up and shake your hand you're not
looking at me as a threat because my
energy matches it's clean and neat and
so you can establish whatever you want
to establish based on that now that's an
investment into what I do but whatever
it is you got going on you know you got
your own camera your own right
microphones you know I mean all of that
is an investment into yourself and
saving is it's important but everybody
always say you should save for a rainy
day and you know the rainy days and
that's cool but what are you gonna do if
you got the money and the rain comes and
it doesn't help gonna lose it all
because you're gonna think you got to
spend it on must not be spending enough
I must not be saving enough to feel
comfortable you kind of you can't put
your in my opinion you can't put your
interest in just having financial
success because it's important as
financial success is especially in
America you got to have some type of
peace of mind to go with that so you
know save some money in order to invest
in yourself but once you invest in
yourself then you know you'll stop
thinking about it
like the thing that I think
getting into certain circles does it
lets you realize that the conversation
is no longer about money when I was
broke all we talked about was getting
some money now that I'm not broke
anymore
we really have conversations amongst the
people that I'm around about money
because it's not even anything to talk
about but it takes you to get something
to learn that I'm not saying you know
listen to this and just think that I'm
saying you don't need money you need
some money I hope you get some so you
can learn how to use that within
yourself but once you start to make it
for real and make some money then you
realize that it's really not something
that people discuss when they don't have
to so the quicker you get out of letting
that be the motivating factor for
whatever it is you do then the quicker
you'll see that you know it's gonna come
to you and you've been around I mean you
know Diddy like Steve Harvey and all
like the 1% of 1% right on this planet
the high end of the high end yo so it's
like what it what have you learned
you've seen you've seen that world's
like what have you learned being in that
environment maybe you could share with
listeners I'm a big energy person I
believe I'm not a religious person you
know I mean I don't I don't you know
believe and I believe in I believe
there's a god but I don't believe in the
religious aspects believe in the glow I
believe yes right now that's my favorite
last drag and I got a pain in the Bruce
Leroy hanging over my bed but the glow
and that's another person that I would
love to meet Barry Gordy cuz just to
shake his hand and thank him for giving
the game that he gave in that movie but
I believe in energy kind of let's just
use as an example to glow like the point
of that movie was to let you know that
it's already in you you are the master
you already been the master but you just
had if the whole movie was him figuring
out who he was and the journey that he
had to go through to get that and at the
end of the movie when sho'nuff was
beating the [ __ ] out of him and putting
his head in the water and he lifts him
up and said who's the master and he
looked at him and said I am he went
through all of the different lessons
that he had learned to get to the point
of having a glow but the glow to me is
just
what projects out of you and the more
you become accepting of the fact that
you got it the bigger it gets so for me
what I learned the most about being
around guys like Diddy and Steve Harvey
and Nick Cannon and all these different
cyber people is that I have the type of
glow that is comparable to those guys my
energy fits into a space with Giants
live you know I mean and I'm not there
in regards to the status aspect of it
but my energy is enough to fit into a
space where all of this exists so it's
like that's what I felt about walking
into a room and seeing somebody who it's
like whoa you know I mean and on the
video if you watch it did he walked up
to me and was like Chico what's going on
man you changed your diet
I was like whoa not only this is my
[ __ ] know me he know me well enough
to know what I used to look like yeah
you know that right there is that's the
energy to me it's just being able to
know that because we all got big balls
of energy that's in front of us and you
ever you ever walk into a room and
somebody comes it's like it's two type
of people it's people that walk into a
room and change the energy and there's
people who walk out of a room and change
the energy mm-hmm so you can be one of
the two people you can be one of the
people who walk into a room and the room
brightens up or you're gonna be one of
the people who leave out of the room and
it brightens up so to know that I'm one
of the people who walk into a room and
brighten it up is one thing but to walk
into a room with with giants and they
still smile when they see you and say
what something when they see you that
means that you got I got the type of
energy that I need to keep curating and
feeding that to get to a point where
they because that's what they did in my
opinion I mean so that's really what I
learned the most about being able to be
in these spaces that me and the people
that I'm surrounded by
we have a unique type of and a special
type of energy man and the energy that
we project is so big at this point that
you can share the room with people who
will live forever you know I mean that's
that's what is so mind-blowing about
this 85 South
I don't recall - oh it's like a movement
it's like a revolution like the impact
that 85 South is making not just on the
comedy game but like entertainment it's
like unfounded what you guys are
achieving and I've talked to Chad the
producer in Carlos and Clayton we're
like what is your take on 85 South and
why it is having the impact that it has
one because it's genuine this is a
genuine relationship that we have like
fly came in what two seasons after we
came in but he fit right in and and just
when we communicated with each other it
was just always genuine so that's the
basis of it okay but one of the major
things that I think it is I mean a hotel
lobby right now we are know this is the
mud this is the come up this is the
hotel and they excited you know you guys
went from like the studios the trap yeah
you know this and that's the thing like
the only way that that can happen is
just if it's genuine you have to be
excited about going to do whatever it is
you're going to do and one of the major
things I think that makes what we do a
little different is that we all hold our
own in our own right I got shows in
Atlanta this weekend DC was in
Pittsburgh last week I mean just
yesterday Carlos is in Cincinnati Ohio
headlining the funny bone all weekend so
we all do what we do individually but we
come together and get on stage together
you know Kings of Comedy is a legendary
movie because you imagine if we got the
sort you got two CDL you know I mean say
it Bernie and Steve come out together
and talk [ __ ] together that's a whole
nother movie right you know so I think
that's really what gives people the
different feel you've never seen it done
that way before and it's all improv it
should be magic to us to like we don't
practice anything we get on stage and we
go you know I mean we got my man Craig
right here I'm gonna test it that we
never sit around and have no meetings
about iPhone we in this city so that's
what we got none of that because it's so
genuine and like I said that energy that
I was talking about it's so strong and
it's so genuine that when we get on
stage it's literally magic so I think
that most people can see that and even
the people who may have negative
opinions about what we do cuz you know
you see all of that it doesn't that
doesn't matter
you know I mean because that is the same
type of effect that the positive energy
has even though you don't like it it's
affected you some type of way and what
it is that we do has made you feel real
emotion so that means it's something
special I heard somebody say there
Martin wasn't funny the other day I
looked at him like they was crazy but he
was able to sit and have a conversation
to me as to why he didn't which means
you watched it long enough to develop
the opinion that you had so it really
doesn't change in regards to the what
I'm giving you or what what Martin did
in regards to giving you that show he
gave it to you and because he gave it to
you he was able to formulate something
that lasted for long after he stopped
doing it and still have people having
conversations about it right now and
that's the type of energy that we create
with the 85 like god forbid if we was to
stop tomorrow the things that we've done
up until this point I feel like will be
talked about for a long time because
people haven't even really grasped the
reality of it like to go back and watch
like these guys are really doing
something completely different so I just
think that the reason why we're able to
you know do what we do not necessarily
the success because that just came
organically but the reason why we're
able to do what we do is because it was
just based in a genuine heesu we
brothers for real you know I mean we
don't sit around and talk about work we
talk about life you know I mean like we
know each other's children fam
I've been to these people's house and
hugged their mothers you know I mean
like all of us you know it's just a
different type of environment and for us
to be able to have that type of
Brotherhood and still be able to get on
stage and share the light it's amazing
and the eighty five percenters
definitely reflect that
yeah they serious you know I may not and
in there is it's in this it's it's crazy
to me because you know all around is
just a blessing man it's just a super
blessing because like I said like we've
been talking about this whole time my
perspective is different in losest
perspective is different lies
perspective is different so a lot of the
things that will probably cause
dissension or cause disruption amongst
this process just doesn't affect us the
same way I've seen people you know we
work in all different types of violence
I've seen how opinions affect people
I've seen people really look at comments
that people leave and be truly like
deflated right there's no way I can be
deflated about anybody's opinion you are
entitled to your opinion but I'm
entitled not to give a [ __ ] about you
know I mean and that's whether it be
whatever it may be but none of us allow
what they say quote unquote to affect
what we do you know I'm saying I'm gonna
be me regardless of whether or not you
like it or not you don't have to like it
but until you decide to get up and do
something that's gonna stop me from
doing what I do you're gonna have to
just keep not liking it but I've seen
the people that do like it you guys are
like the Beatles out there yeah I mean
no it's that's the people's or anything
the people who do love it like that's
something no I'd like to look at life in
the regards to this you don't have to
know what you want you just have to know
what you don't want hmm
and don't like so as long as you knows
you don't like you're good the love the
only matter like that goes without
saying because that isn't what
somebody's gonna need motivation on so I
don't even like to
really discussed those type of things
because you don't need no motivation on
how to deal with love but the negative
stuff and they hate that comedians and
entertainers get is what I see deflate
them so offer I can offer any type of
perspective it'll be based in that
because the love is the love you don't
need no preparation for love love is
love and whenever you get it she won't
know it's love
I had a dude in the mall walk up on me
man literally she go oh you knew I
appreciate you bro I'm walking away with
an eight and it's like you don't have to
prepare for that no I mean that doesn't
take any preparation because you're able
to receive that however you receive it
but it's the other stuff that you have
to prepare yourself for the stuff that
you don't want so once you prepare
yourself for the stuff that you don't
want everything that you want just
becomes that much more magnified because
the things you don't want don't affect
your ability to recognize the things
that you do mm-hmm
and the the come up as will land this
plane here is one thing that helps
comedians keep perspective is like
bombing on stage and I asked every
comedian on here like a story of getting
booed or like just an unforgettable show
there was just everything went wrong
right like do you have one top of mine
and this is how crazy it happens for me
okay it's not unique I am as a human
being my first show I used to do to open
mic night at the Greensboro comedies on
every first and second Thursday of the
month right so I went the first thirst
because I never been to a comedy club
before this point like I didn't grow up
thinking I'll be a comedian that was not
at all it wasn't my in my goals until I
started your me a cameraman right now I
was going to be a news anchor news
anchor hey yeah when I was in college I
thought I was gonna be a news anchor
when I was young I thought I was just
gonna be rich dope Dylan Street [ __ ]
okay that was it I thought that was what
you wanted to do until my uncle got
murdered and I was like oh yeah this
ain't it cuz he was a hundred times
tougher than I can ever be and I knew
that and I said well if that's what his
fate was oh I know what they got for me
I had to do that because I was trained
by these people so I know the reality of
being out there in that environment is
you know you hear people say it all the
time you're gonna deaf for jail but the
reality is death or jail like when you
see death in jail right next to you it
has a different type of feeling than it
does when people just saying it to you
because if you're never experienced it
you don't know what it felt like to have
to view a body or to have to you know
smell a person clothes that's gone
forever you know I mean those little
nuances that people don't recognize but
once I got on stage at the second open
mic night was the second week after I
went to the first show four minutes
killed in my mind which I know now been
in the game you can't really kill in
four minutes but in that four minutes I
smashed so at that point I'm in it the
very next open mic night the month after
which is September I went up with the
confidence of Richard Pryor Chappelle
[ __ ] I'm talking about it was you
couldn't tell me that I wasn't do Bernie
Harvey I'm telling I was everybody I got
on a stage and a me I'm come out it was
me and for some reason wasn't it was
probably like I say 40 50 people at the
first open mic that did this one was
packed all white people and I got on
stage talking some [ __ ] and they was
just like and this is the thing booing
is different
cuz boring means you've affected the
people some type of what acts that means
you invoke some type of emotion to it
boo [ __ ] you [ __ ]
but when that silence that means that
they don't have a clue how to feel about
what you're doing up there and that
silence is nasty it's two types of
silences in comedy that I've learned at
least in my experience is the silence of
say next that quiet that comes over the
room so they can hear everything that
you're saying and then it's that quiet
of who's next what's next and who's next
I was in the who's next I mean they just
was like
and that was one of the biggest lessons
that I've ever learned but luckily for
me that wasn't the first time that that
happened to me I'm in the fraternity so
I remember me and my fraternity went to
Indianapolis to step in the Circle City
Classic and we had this thing where we
was like old man we had these goofy wigs
and suspenders and all that and this was
a step show in arena you're like it was
an arena and I'm talking about
we got no love it was so bad that the
people who came from our school was
scared to even clap cuz they don't want
nobody to know we was with you
so it humbled me once I got off stage
that time like no this ain't the thing
that's just going you got the work
problem that the work you got to really
work and from that moment on I've worked
and luckily in that work I already had
to establish if I don't care about what
nobody thinks about give a [ __ ] what you
think you know you can think whatever
you want to think about me so on you god
bless you but I'm gonna work and even if
you don't appreciate what I do or don't
like what I do you're gonna have to
respect the fact that he doing it and
that's the part that has always kept me
in my own pocket you know I mean being
able to be comfortable onstage and being
honest onstage because I don't care
about what you think about the things
that I love you know I mean I know the
people who love me unconditionally
and I make sure that I do everything in
my power to make sure that it stays that
way
everybody else is just somebody who is
formulating an opinion based off what I
do and you were entitled to that and I'm
gonna continue to do what I do and you
can continue to formulate the opinions
that you choose to formulate around it
but I'm gonna work work it's what it's
about man we made it this is what this
is what it's about right here right like
how how unique is it to be drinking some
hot breath water negative I it tastes
like slob it's pontus water this is very
good Georgia Georgia mountain spring
water Georgia mountains on
Mountain spring water listen you got to
be from some veal to be able to find
your own spring so I'm saying got it
listen great we had enough white people
man we got a gives of white people
he's the plug he got a spring most
[ __ ] got hookups on you know [ __ ]
rims and [ __ ] like that
you got a hookup on a spring hey man
come on down to some field we got a
spring that you can go down there and
bother you some water up I got water and
whites so whatever y'all need that's
what they they they a man we wish you
might appreciate this is cool man I
appreciate you for having me over here I
appreciate you being on here man and
we've been we've been chipping away at
the 85 South gang we've just got DC left
oh yeah that's gonna be a good one man
you know that's gonna be good like
that's definitely gonna be a good one
man
you know but this is these type of
conversations are necessary and you know
if I can be any motivation to anyone
who's out here trying to pursue this as
a career pursue this as a dream my
biggest advice would be block out the
[ __ ] man whatever you consider the
[ __ ] to be block it out figure out
how you can block it out and then once
you block it out start walking and keep
on walking well I mean based on our
conversation would you mind looking into
the camera and tell people who you are
and why they should listen to hot breath
podcast my name is Chieko bean and the
reason why you should listen to hot
breath podcast is because this
[ __ ] got his own water alright
remember how Prince I came had his own
money he got his own water and he
dressed like a real estate lawyer not a
real estate agent he's a real estate
lawyer cuz he both you know you can call
him to get a house and if your back got
broken a car accident that's why you
should watch high breath podcasts
because it's unique this dude doesn't
fit any mold of what somebody supposed
to look like which is the reason why he
can bring you all different type of
content because you know he's not
setting any type of way he's setting
work and that's what it's about so make
sure you supporting damn it breath hot
breath water I don't make your breath
hat because it's from a natural spring
in some veal there's only he can get too
so that that's it hot breath averse
you've heard it from the man himself
Chico bean if you enjoyed this hot
breath Assad reach out to him directly
on social media let him know how helpful
this episode was at the end of the day
determine what success is to you and
then start yep put in the work so we
appreciate your support are in hot
breath if you love us if you like us you
want to support us hot breath podcast
calm is the website all social media hot
breath pod Joel Byers comedy calm long
story short we're on YouTube as well if
you want to see this man live and in
living color but this is a milestone in
this show for sure I don't they have no
doubt thank you so much for being on
your cheek I appreciate you
[Music]
I breath